[Música]
comenzó esta semana una nueva mesa de
diálogo con la intención de poner fin a
casi seis décadas de conflicto armado en
Colombia una guerra que ha dejado hasta
el momento unos 450,000 muertos hay
muchísima expectativa internacional en
torno a esta mesa de negociación veamos
los colombianos no podemos vernos como
enemigos
la labor que tenemos es de
Reconciliación de volver a encontrar
unos puntos comunes de construir una
nación en paz y equidad
es el apuesta que nosotros traemos Y a
eso venimos a esta mesa y esperamos de
la delegación del gobierno tener un
interlocutor en el mismo sentido el
primer encuentro que hemos sostenido en
la mañana de hoy con la delegación
de paz del Ln
Nos está dando certezas y la convicción
profunda de que vamos a lograr el
propósito que nos suma
ser hijas e hijos de una misma patria
con cambios y transformaciones Pues esta
mesa de diálogo entre el gobierno y la
guerrilla del Ln hace parte de ese
proyecto pasto tal que busca el
presidente colombiano Gustavo Petro
quien prometió poner fin a la
confrontación veamos algunos datos
básicos para entender el contexto
colombiano estos diálogos de paz tienen
su sede principal en la ciudad de
Caracas la capital de Venezuela Allí se
reúnen cara a cara representantes del
gobierno de Colombia e integrantes del
ejército de liberación nacional el eln
dichos diálogos cuentan también con el
apoyo de varios países garantes entre
ellos están Cuba Noruega y Venezuela y
también tienen el apoyo de la Iglesia
Católica de Colombia También tienen el
aval también cuentan con el apoyo de la
Organización de las Naciones Unidas ONU
y un dato en dicha mesa de diálogo no
participa o por lo menos no hay
representantes de los militares
colombianos solo hay dos militares que
están dentro de la delegación del
gobierno colombiano y están allí como
observadores pero pongamos los a ustedes
nuestros televidentes fuera de las
fronteras colombianas en contexto sobre
Qué es el ejército de liberación
nacional o simplemente conocido como eln
pues es una guerrilla inspirada en la
revolución cubana pero que también tiene
una fuerte dosis o componente de
inspiración religiosa fue la segunda
guerrilla más grande de Colombia después
de la extinta guerrilla de las FARC se
calcula que tiene unos 1500 combatientes
y sus frentes gozan digamos de bastante
autonomía por parte de los líderes
máximos de este grupo guerrillero el Ln
hace presencia en su mayoría en zonas de
donde hay presencia minera y petrolera
en Colombia en el pasado
junto con el gobierno en otros cinco
intentos de negociación el último el más
reciente de ellos comenzó durante el
gobierno del ex presidente Juan Manuel
Santos y terminó durante la
administración de la expresidente Iván
Duque debido a un atentado que fue
perpetrado por lln en enero de 2019 en
una Escuela Militar en la ciudad de
Bogotá que dejó 22 muertos como lo decía
Pues hay mucha expectativa frente a esta
mesa de diálogo porque su éxito no
solamente pondría fin a décadas de
enfrentamientos con esta guerrilla en
Colombia sino que también puede
garantizar la apertura dentro de ese
marco de la paz total para comenzar una
negociación con otros grupos
delincuenciales menores pero que no son
menos peligrosos los compromisos que
adopten las partes negociadoras no van a
ser fáciles de lograr sin duda alguna
Pero hay voluntad de las partes o por lo
menos así lo están demostrando hasta el
momento por ejemplo el Ln puso sobre la
mesa un pacto de no agresión entre la
guerrilla y los militares para poder dar
inicio a estos diálogos
era un punto que en el pasado en las
otras mesas de diálogo era muy difícil
de lograr y era muy difícil de convencer
por lo menos al Ln de dejar los combates
por lo menos mientras conversaban las
partes pero esta negociación tiene lugar
eso también hay que decirlo mientras la
violencia en general se incrementan
diferentes zonas Rurales de Colombia por
diferentes causas y también por
diferentes actores No necesariamente por
el Ln particularmente es muy crítica la
situación que se está viviendo en el
departamento del putumayo que está
ubicado en el sur del país esto nos
lleva entonces a poner diferentes
preguntas sobre la mesa qué está en
juego en esta negociación qué elecciones
dejó ese acuerdo de paz que alcanzaron
con la extinta guerrilla de las FARC que
puede replicarse en este escenario
actual podrá Colombia alcanzar esa
añorada Paz total y esa eslogan de
bandera y de campaña del presidente
Gustavo Petro que hay de esos grupos
delincuenciales que les estaban
mencionando que también hacen presencia
en Colombia van a sentarse a negociar lo
vamos a analizar en el debate de France
24 y para conversar y analizar este tema
hemos invitado a Alejandra Cerón Rincón
ella es socióloga de la Universidad
Nacional de Colombia investigadora en la
línea de políticas públicas para el
sector de defensa y educación se conecta
desde la ciudad de Bogotá la capital
colombiana y desde la ciudad de ibagué
en el centro de Colombia se une a esta
conversación Ricardo ferro él es ex
congresista por el partido centro
democrático ustedes nuestros
televidentes también hacen parte de la
discusión del debate de la conversación
pueden dejar todos sus comentarios y
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
estamos en Twitter en Facebook en
instagram ustedes ya lo saben nos
encuentran como arroba el debate guión
bajo
f24@santilogo que es mi cuenta personal
la etiqueta para que dejen los
comentarios numeral el debate f24 no
olviden que también los contenidos del
programa están disponibles en podcast
estamos en diferentes plataformas
estamos en Apple podcast en Spotify
deezer iTunes poco a creciendo nuestra
comunidad de oyentes a través de las
diferentes plataformas de podcast
muy bien Le doy la bienvenida entonces a
Alejandra en la ciudad de Bogotá para
conocer su opinión nuestro Punto de
partida Alejandra es la misma pregunta
para los dos invitados para conocer
posiciones sobre este tema su opinión
sobre el inicio de esta mesa de diálogo
en Caracas entre el Ln y el gobierno
colombiano bienvenida
bueno Santiago Muchísimas gracias por la
invitación en primera instancia y como
colombiana hay que decir que
definitivamente como sociedad civil
nosotros aplaudimos y vemos con muy
buenos ojos la el un nuevo intento por
firmar la paz con lln usted decía con
mucha razón que hay muchas cosas en
juego muchos escenarios políticos y
muchos elementos que que tienen que ser
discutidos el primero y el más
importante realmente Pues en la
candidatura y toda todo el ejercicio
político que hace el presidente Petro
siendo un presidente de izquierda o de
izquierdas Vamos a ponerle el plural
porque ahí hay como muchos movimientos
sociales y muchas ideologías las que
están dentro de este escenario pues se
la pues te apuestan por la paz muchos de
los votantes muchos de los simpatizantes
estuvieron de acuerdo con que realmente
el escenario más importante que
necesitamos los colombianos es el tema
de la paz y definitivamente del
desarrollo de
un diálogos y de la de la posible
concertación de una paz con el Ln Pues
están Están digamos pendiendo en buena
medida los triunfos del gobierno Petro y
en general de el proyecto progresista no
solo en Colombia sino en América Latina
en un segundo espacio no perder de vista
que estamos negociando con la última
guerrilla Viva en Colombia esto quiere
decir que estamos negociando con un
grupo que a pesar de Y ustedes lo
podemos discutir ampliamente a pesar de
que obviamente los elementos conexos al
crimen organizado están presentes en la
forma de vida de esta guerrilla aún
permanecen los elementos ideológicos la
guerrilla del Ln desde sus inicios ha
sido muy clara y muy fuerte en esta
formación paradigmática en construir ese
ese eje que viene que tiene pues
vertientes de izquierda de la teología
la liberación del escenario de las
nuevas izquierdas entonces todo esto
también le da como un quiebre es
importante esta negociación la opinión
de Alejandra nuestra primera en el
programa de hoy le doy la palabra ahora
a Ricardo en la ciudad de ibagué en el
departamento de tolima en el centro de
Colombia Ricardo Bienvenido al programa
Gracias por acompañarnos hoy y cuál es
su opinión sobre el inicio de esta mesa
de diálogo
Santiago un saludo muy especial para
usted para Alejandra para todos los
televidentes
a esta hora del día bueno en lo primero
es decir que hay que llamar las cosas
por su nombre aquí en Colombia en la
última década a raíz de lo que fue la
campaña de reelección de Juan Manuel
Santos en el 2014 se le dio por llamar
procesos de paz a los procesos de
desmovilización de grupos guerrilleros
una cosa es un proceso de paz otra cosa
es un proceso de paz total y otra cosa
es un proceso de desmovilización de un
grupo guerrillero aquí tenemos
nuevamente al igual que se presentó en
la década anterior un proceso
movilización de un grupo guerrillero en
el en la década anterior se
desmovilizaron las FARC entre comillas
porque ahí vemos como muchos de esos que
en teoría se movilizaron a un siguiente
limpiando ahorita se llaman grupos
residuales tan es así que a las FARC que
se suponía que después de movilizarse se
iba a convertir en un partido político a
ese partido político las FARC de todo
cambiar de nombre para que no lo
confundieran con el grupo residual de
las parques sigue del inquiendo ahora
tenemos el grupo lln quien tampoco nos
va a llevar a una tal a la supuesta Paz
total porque aquí hay muchos grupos al
margen de la ley en Colombia aquí
estamos es ante un proceso de
desmovilización de un grupo guerrillero
y como proceso de movilización es que se
debe tratar por parte del Estado esto no
nos puede llevar a nosotros a una a
tener unas falsas expectativas sobre las
consecuencias de este proceso es
movilización
y finalmente el Ln termine el
movilizándose Ojalá y no nos salga tan
caro A los colombianos la
desmovilización del lln o de los
guerrilleros de lln que se quieran
desmovilizar pero Vuelvo y repito aquí
lo fundamental es que no nos llamemos
engaños aquí no va a haber una paz total
aquí sigue habiendo unos grupos tanto
guerrilleros como otros grupos al margen
de la ley que como usted lo menciona al
principio de su intervención Santiago
tenemos un incremento de la de la
violencia en nuestro país en los últimos
días que realmente es lo que está
llamando a a o está o está reflejando lo
que es la realidad hoy en día de la
situación de orden público en nuestro
país Entonces esto es un pequeño grupo o
una o una parte del conflicto que hoy en
día está viviendo nuestro país lo que
tiene que ver en lln regreso con
Alejandra en la ciudad de Bogotá
Alejandro usted ya daba algunos puntos
básicos de esos factores que se han ido
sumando para que sea posible esta mesa
de diálogo no solamente el hecho que sea
impulsado por Gustavo Petro un
presidente que representa a la izquierda
colombiana los o el espectro de la
izquierda en Colombia que otros factores
se han sumado a ese impulso que le da al
presidente petrota a través de su
política de la paz total para que sea
posible que este diálogo haya comenzado
en Caracas
Bueno aquí hay otros elementos como como
bien usted menciona Santiago en primera
instancia recordar que también hay un
obviamente todo cambio de gobierno
implica una transformación en el
discurso político y en ese discurso
político está jugando mucho en lo que es
en el contexto de seguridad lo que son
los determinantes y los marcos de acción
de la seguridad humana Entonces por
supuesto bien lo mencionado usted todas
las influencias de los grupos
guerrilleros en Colombia
desafortunadamente han recaído y han
tenido un impacto muy grande en la
población y la población rural
colombiana en eso que ha sido denominado
por muchos historiadores de la Colombia
profunda en el sentido de que pues todas
las estructuras económicas y sociales
han empezado a girar en torno a la
violencia Entonces es muy importante que
en este proceso o que los resultados de
este proceso terminen por configurar
digamos un impacto grande en términos
políticos de Qué significa la seguridad
humana y de cómo la vida humana tiene
que pasar a un primer plano en el
análisis y en la intención Pues de
beligerantes en Colombia Por una parte
Por otra parte por supuesto el hecho que
se haya escogido a Venezuela y la
reciente
dinamización de la y digamos reubicación
en el panorama geopolítico de las
relaciones Colombia Venezuela Pues
también está están allí o sea el ojo de
la opinión pública el interés de la
comunidad internacional por el Construir
la paz por la participación de los
territorios y dentro de eso también por
la vuelta a la democracia puede ser un
elemento que también está muy digamos en
en el marco de análisis y de acción de
lo que pueda pasar en el proceso de paz
y un último elemento que a mí también me
gustaría mencionar es el resultado lo
que lo que podríamos esperar lo que
viene hacia adelante de que en el hecho
de que se haya se hayan convocado a
distintos sectores al diálogo entonces
vemos que hay representación de
empresarios vemos que hay digamos
también una una apertura amplia que el
Ln sugirió frente a sus negociadores y
obviamente pues también lo que se espera
De qué manera se desarrollar sí que es
el acompañamiento de las fuerzas
militares
Ricardo paso a darle la palabra usted en
la ciudad de ibagué para presentar para
preguntarle justamente por un actor
importante por ser un país garante y por
ser el país sede de esta mesa de
negociación y es Venezuela Qué opinión
tiene usted sobre la presencia de
Venezuela en esta mesa de conversaciones
a raíz de esas relaciones tirantes que
había entre Bogotá y Caracas
lo que esperamos nosotros es que en este
proceso de desmovilización del lln el
papel que juegue Venezuela no sea el que
ha venido jugando los últimos años con
los grupos guerrilleros que es el
alcahuete de al lado es el que es donde
se esconden todos los bandidos que
delinquen en Colombia o la gran mayoría
de los bandidos van y se esconden en
Venezuela y que han sido arropados por
el régimen de Nicolás maduro y antes por
el régimen de Chávez Esperamos que ahora
que hay un hay un diálogo que se va a
dar un diálogo en Venezuela eso de
alguna manera represente un cambio de
actitud por parte de Venezuela hacia
hacia su vecino hacia Colombia aquí lo
que hay de por medio son unos bandidos
unos delincuentes unos terroristas unas
personas que han delinquido Yo entiendo
que la paz se tiene que hacer con los
enemigos pero en este caso que ojalá y
que no terminemos en un proceso también
de impunidad
a unas personas que le han hecho mucho
daño al pueblo colombiano Precisamente
en estos días en los medios de
comunicación se mencionaba que una de
las negociadoras del Ln fue Ni más ni
menos que una persona que puso una bomba
en un Mall en un centro comercial de la
ciudad de Bogotá y donde perdimos la
vida varias personas entonces ese tipo
de de de personas más allá de que estén
sentadas en una mesa de negociación
tienen que ser conscientes del daño que
han causado a otros seres humanos y que
eso no puede quedar en la impunidad aquí
tenemos nosotros que
dentro de este proceso de movilización
del Ln entender que tiene que haber una
responsabilidad y tiene que pagarse por
cuenta de los delitos que se hayan
cometido
Alejandra su opinión sobre el papel que
tiene que jugar Venezuela en esta
negociación Y por qué Venezuela es
importante en esta mesa de diálogo
pues como yo le comentaba a Santiago es
muy importante que Venezuela participe
porque implica pues como bien bien
Afirma Ricardo
desafortunadamente parte de la
construcción del crimen organizado
transnacional que sufre que se sufre hoy
en la región pues está afectando estas
zonas donde se comparte frontera
Venezuela Colombia entonces realmente la
participación de Venezuela también tiene
que ir con un interés hacia la
construcción de una seguridad regional y
de una seguridad colectiva Por una parte
pero también por otra parte pienso yo
Que es un espacio en el cual pues
Venezuela también puede empezar a buscar
este camino hasta la democracia plena
esa restitución de la democracia y hacer
mirado con otros ojos desde la comunidad
internacional entonces me parece que eso
eso es clave allí y también también Así
es clave y es difícil se entiende que es
complicado el hecho de entender que
realmente en los procesos de pues
quienes van a estar allí pues han sido
los actores de la guerra no no pueden
ser otros y es y es y es Tal vez es a la
parte más difícil para que pues primero
la sociedad civil confíe y en general la
comida internacional
empiece a ver que hay una voluntad
política y que esa voluntad política
deberá superar formas de de acción y de
y de financiación hay que decirlo de
estos grupos Que obviamente han afectado
mucho la posibilidad de que haya un
acuerdo político sin embargo creo que el
hecho de las de las elecciones los
resultados en Colombia y el interés de
la gente por mantener la paz prevalencia
Ricardo Colombia es un país que ya vivió
un proceso similar no es el mismo tipo
de proceso con la extinta guerrilla de
las FARC hoy en día convertida en un
partido político en qué lecciones Y qué
errores se cometieron en esa negociación
que no deben cometerse en esta mesa de
diálogo en este proceso que usted llama
desmovilización pero que para otros es
un proceso de paz dependiendo del punto
de vista que se le mire que no se debe
repetir ahí
Bueno ahí hay varias cosas varios
errores que se cometieron uno uno fue
generar en la opinión pública unas
expectativas que no se cumplieron eso es
como cuando a un niño chiquito se le
cuenta el cuento de hadas en donde
primero se derrota al dragón después se
casa el príncipe con la princesa y
después vivieron felices y comieron
perdices aquí se le dijo a la gente que
después del proceso de paz íbamos a
vivir felices y comer perdices en
Colombia y resulta que no hubo tal
primero porque no se hizo la paz y por
eso mi llamado a que no se llame un
proceso de paz no se hizo la paz con
todos los actores del conflicto usted no
puede hablar de paz Cuando sigue
teniendo actores del conflicto por fuera
de una negociación ahí es un proceso de
desmovilización Entonces es importante
que las expectativas sean realmente las
que se esperan hombre tenemos unas zonas
de influencia del Ln en donde hay un hay
unos índices de violencia muy alto
entonces lo que necesitamos es
recuperar esas áreas del territorio va a
ser fundamental este proceso de
desmovilización de lln en segundo lugar
no podemos tampoco entregarle a lln todo
lo que quieran pedir a cambio de que
hagan este proceso de movilización
porque está está claro que en el en el
proceso de desmovilización de las FARC
el estado se sobregiro y termina
incumpliendo todos los compromisos que
se adquieren finalmente porque no hay
por un lado ni el presupuesto es
suficiente para cumplir con todas las
exigencias que se tiene por parte de un
grupo de movilización ni por otro lado
Tampoco puede haber los espacios
políticos que alguna de alguna manera
miren en la participación ciudadana del
resto del país en lo que tiene que ver
con la representación en en órganos o en
en en entes como el congreso de la
República entonces tiene que ser
consecuente el proceso de movilización
con la representación o la
representatividad que debe ese grupo
guerrillero dentro del Congreso de la
República y En tercer lugar hay algo muy
importante y es la impunidad nosotros no
podemos
conectar con la impunidad vea usted como
todos los compromisos que adquirieron
las Farc en su momento para la
desmovilización no se cumplieron no
pueden decir que van a reparar a las
víctimas Sencillamente con unos con unas
escobas viejas y con unos recogedores
porque todo el mundo tiene Claro que
dentro de las actividades ilícitas que
tenía este grupo guerrillero estaba
precisamente todo el tema de los
secuestros la extorsión y era un grupo
guerrillero que realmente tenía Cómo
reparar las víctimas y no lo quiso hacer
ahora con el Ln esos errores no se
pueden cometer No puede haber impunidad
y no se pueden faltar a los compromisos
de reparación a las víctimas Alejandra
le hago la misma pregunta que no se
puede repetir y le prolongó un poco la
la pregunta para ver La otra cara de la
moneda que se puede aplicar en ese
proceso con las Farc también entendiendo
que son dos tipos de guerrilla
completamente diferentes
para esta negociación que ha funcionado
de ese proceso de paz que ha sido
tortuoso largo con muchas discrepancias
dentro de la sociedad y la política
colombiana y que en algunos puntos y En
algunos momentos incluso ha estado
completamente paralizado pero algo
positivo pudo haber arrojado que puede
ser aplicado ahora
Bueno sí inicialmente creo yo que lo que
lo que esté aprendió es que
definitivamente un proceso de paz estéis
es un proceso es una cosa de largo
aliento mucha gente consideraba o de
pronto por las expectativas de de pronto
del hecho de que tantas décadas en
conflicto en Colombia y hasta ahora se
pusiera sobre el tema la mesa sobre la
mesa la discusión de la paz pues
pareciera que una firma de un acuerdo
era la solución pero pues
definitivamente las condiciones el mismo
acuerdo de paz que firmó la la guerrilla
las FARC con el gobierno del presidente
Santos en ese momento reconoció que hay
una serie de elementos estructurales
problemáticos que de alguna manera
alientan el problema de de de de de de
de la insurgencia en Colombia que bueno
en su momento en los años 60 fue
insurgencia y que hoy pues es muy
difícil establecer ese límite eso es
totalmente cierto el tema La
criminalidad se ha aminado mucho la
ideología y la capacidad de estos grupos
para para hacer propuesta política pero
se aprende se aprende que
definitivamente es un proceso y hay que
continuar en la búsqueda de este proceso
porque pues finalmente la sociedad
colombiana lo requiere no sólo desde las
posibilidades éticas sociales sino
también económicas el hecho de la guerra
ha frenado mucho las dinámicas de de la
economía sobre todo en la parte en la
parte Rurales de Colombia que Hoy
empiezan a depender prácticamente
de la influencia de los grupos de crimen
organizado también se aprende Creo yo
que esto es muy importante que
definitivamente el cese al conflicto
genera una serie de compromisos
distintos para las instituciones Sí
entonces así quienes cuando o sea
definitivamente el incumplimiento de los
acuerdos es una parte que que tiene que
estar sonando y que y que y que se ha
hecho mucha referencia En este gobierno
y a toda persona y a toda institución
que quiera negociar la paz tiene que
reconocer que el incumplimiento pues
obviamente va a minar y va a fracturar
pero igual manera en la medida en que
hay acuerdos fíjense que las
instituciones totales tienen que
plantearse una serie de
responsabilidades y una serie de cambios
y nuevas actividades para responder a
esa paz Que obviamente lo interesante de
esto y lo que nosotros hacemos nosotros
los académicos es empezar como a
estudiar es esta visión digamos de un
mundo más contemporáneo Entonces no
perdamos de vista lo que pasó en Irlanda
lo que pasa en otros procesos de paz que
pueden tener eventualmente condiciones
parecidas en el sentido de que hay que
se quebranta mucho la visión de estos
grupos frente a la sociedad civil
Ricardo Lo mencionaba yo en la
introducción del programa que para esta
mesa de diálogo por lo menos para esta
primera parte No hay presencia no hay
representación de los militares
colombianos dos de ellos hacen parte del
equipo del gobierno colombiano pero
están simplemente como observadores esto
que que se puede analizar que no haya
presencia de los militares que son los
que directamente están en el campo de
batalla contra la guerrilla a lo largo
de todos estos años
Santiago antes de contestarle esa
pregunta Permítame complementar la
anterior rápidamente y es con lo
siguiente hay dos errores que no se
pueden cometer tampoco en este proceso
de negociación uno el tema de considerar
el narcotráfico como un delito político
Eso es gravísimo para el país y más para
un país como el nuestro con los
problemas que tenemos de narcotráfico
tan grande con casi 300.000 hectáreas de
Coca sembrada aquí tenemos que separar
lo que es son los delitos políticos de
lo que son este tipo de delitos como el
narcotráfico Y en segundo lugar los
delitos atroces delitos como la
violación de niños la violación de
mujeres en fin todos estos delitos
atroces no pueden estar incluidos dentro
de un proceso de negociación con un
grupo guerrillero Porque estos son
delitos diferentes a lo que tiene que
ver propiamente con con lo que se hacen
estos casos en donde está de por medio
única y exclusivamente los delitos
políticos en segundo lugar lo que usted
mencionaba con respecto a la ausencia de
los militares en este en este proceso de
diálogo a mí me parece muy grave que se
sigan tratando a los militares en
Colombia como en un ciudadanos de
segunda tercera o cuarta categoría
Nosotros somos de los poquitos países
del mundo por ejemplo en donde los
militares no pueden votar en donde
nuestras fuerzas armadas no pueden votar
aquí puede votar todo el resto de
ciudadanos menos los militares Entonces
cómo queremos nosotros alcanzar una paz
total Cuando tenemos el senado los
derechos civiles a los a los militares
no estamos hablando de que se hagan
elegir no pero sí que puedan votar que
puedan decidir Quién va a ser el alcalde
el gobernador el presidente de la
república actualmente en Colombia eso no
puede suceder y de la misma manera en
algo tan importante para el país como lo
que tiene que ver con esta
desmovilización Quién es mejor que los
militares para poder arrancar desde ahí
un proceso de diálogo no tienen que ser
los únicos en la mesa pero lo que no
puede suceder es que estén excluidos de
una mesa de negociación y que en ningún
momento van a participar en las
decisiones que se tomen en la misma
Alejandra su opinión el papel de los
militares
bueno Sí definitivamente como Afirma
Ricardo en Colombia nosotros tenemos una
característica Y es que se ha apartado
totalmente de la política a los
militares esto Pues digamos que lo
vieron con buenos ojos nuestras élites
gobernantes desde hace ya más de 50 años
cuando empezaron con con estas
tendencias y independientemente si ellos
pueden o no pueden participar en
política que puede ser otro otro otro
otro episodio que podemos aquí discutir
a mí sí me parece muy necesario que las
voces de los militares tienen que ser
escuchadas no podemos perder de vista lo
que pasó con el informe a la comisión de
la verdad precisamente con el tema de la
paz con las Farc Porque muchos de los
sectores básicamente las familias y las
víctimas de las fuerzas militares en el
conflicto dijeron a nosotros no se nos
tuvo en cuenta no fuimos nuestros
testimonios pareciera no estar allí y
esta podría ser ya que tú estás
preguntando errores y lecciones
aprendidas una lección aprendida y creo
sí que es muy necesario una
participación
de las fuerzas militares en el proceso
pues por lo menos en esta primera fase
de la negociación solamente va a haber
dos de ellos como lo decía como
observadores a lo mejor hay una
modificación en los siguientes
escenarios y se incluyen a los militares
ya veremos que puede pasar más adelante
paso a preguntarle ahora Alejandra para
hacer la ronda la inversa ustedes ya lo
han mencionado aquí hay otros actores
que también están involucrados en este
conflicto interno en Colombia y son los
diferentes grupos delincuenciales o de
crimen organizado que hacen presencia en
diferentes regiones del país yo
mencionaba puntualmente la situación del
putumayo en el sur del país frontera con
Ecuador en donde ha habido recientemente
múltiples ataques confrontación Armada
en donde queda en la mitad la población
civil 20 personas han muerto en los
últimos días en el municipio de Puerto
Guzmán allí en el putumayo estos grupos
delincuenciales han mostrado algún tipo
de intención de involucrarse en este
proceso de paz total o están esperando a
que esta negociación con el Ln pueda dar
frutos llegar a un buen Puerto y un
proceso o simplemente a ellos no les
interesa salir de su negocio criminal
Bueno
no es tan fácil comprometerse que va a
pasar a futuro pero sí es importante y
es necesario reconocer que
desafortunadamente las estructuras
criminales están muy apartadas de creo
yo de una posibilidad o de un interés
por negociar la paz en Colombia
básicamente porque estas estructuras
criminales nunca no podemos olvidar ya
no solamente están delineando en el área
en los empresarios nacionales sino que
muchas de estas estructuras están
apalancadas en la forma del crimen
organizado transnacionales es decir toda
su influencia la búsqueda de sus rutas
tienen que ver con estructuras
criminales a nivel global y en ese
sentido ellas podrían quedar un poco
aparte de los intereses de lo que puede
estar pasando en Colombia además no
perdamos de vista que todo proceso así
como las partes dejó un escenario
residual de personas que no se acogieron
al proceso Igualmente puede pasar esto
con el con el Ln y Pues digamos que ese
es un mal que que va a estar allí y que
parte de los desafíos de la paz
básicamente y a mí me parece que no
podemos perder de vista que el tema del
narcotráfico precisamente también es
objeto de discusión desde el mundo
político internacional de cómo la
política del narcotráfico tiene que
empezar a mirar hacia otros escenarios y
en la medida que esto pase pues
eventualmente podremos ver que haya pues
una un encuentro concomitante o una
coyuntura que podría ser ventajosa para
el para el gobierno Petro pero en
general y sobre todo para el proceso de
paz para tratar de reorientar esta esta
participación de los grupos
delincuencialmente esa denuncia del
fracaso de la lucha antidrogas es
también uno de esos mensajes
internacionales que ha enviado el
presidente Gustavo Petro a lo largo de
estos últimos días en estos 100 primeros
días son poco más que lleva de gobierno
Ricardo cuando uno mira una radiografía
de Colombia y entiende la aparición el
surgimiento de las guerrillas y de todos
estos grupos del narcotráfico y también
los grupos de crimen organizado que
potencia en las diferentes regiones del
país lo que uno entiende es que el
gobierno colombiano el estado colombiano
sigue cometiendo el mismo error a lo
largo de las décadas y Es la falta de
presencia del estado en los rincones del
país Están volviendo a cometer este
error cuando uno ve la proliferación de
estos grupos claramente ningún gobierno
lo ha podido combatir como lo vio usted
Bueno aquí lo que no podemos volver a
permitir o no podemos permitir
nuevamente Es que esto se convierta en
un Carrusel en donde Sencillamente
cambian de cambian de nombre cambian de
de marca pero siguen siendo los mismos
que hay que decirlo con nombre propio
Santiago cuando a las fábricas dieron 10
curules en el congreso que 10 curules es
es una una representación muy grande en
el congreso de la República la
negritudes los grupos indígenas de
nuestro país
sumados no tienen tres cuatro curules en
cambio ellos le dieron diez curules y de
esas 10 curules recuerde usted que cerca
del 20% de esas de esas curules
terminaron otra vez en el monte del
inquinquiendo las personas que estaban
en esas curules es decir se retiraron
del Congreso y se fueron a elegir a
crear las famosas FARC residuales
entonces aquí nosotros hablamos de de un
escenario de negociación con lln y de
cómo vamos a generar este espacio
tenemos que entender que la única forma
de que esto funcione es poder meter en
la negociación a todos los grupos al
margen de la ley de lo contrario
Entonces
los que reciban los beneficios del
proceso de negociación Pues de pronto se
van a quedar en el congreso de la
República o la gran mayoría de ellos los
demás van a volver a delinquir las bases
va a ser muy difícil que siempre
tienen otras oportunidades Ricardo pero
aquí entonces el gran pecado Es la falta
de presencia del Estado colombiano deja
vacíos donde deja espacio para que
existan estos grupos delincuenciales muy
puntual por favor que se me acaba el
tiempo
Hombre Esa es una de las dificultades
que tiene el país pero entonces en ese
orden de ideas eso sería Llamar casi que
a la insurgencia a todas las partes del
país en las cuales ha habido ausencia
del Estado la solución no puede ser
únicamente tratar pues de de por las
vías de hecho llegar a lograr los
objetivos o la presencia del estado Yo
creo que esa no es la solución a la
ausencia del Estado tenemos que a través
de un estado derecho encontrar las
soluciones
Alejandra Cuál es su opinión rápidamente
para el cierre
Y definitivamente La debilidad
institucional y la ausencia Estatal han
sido causa del conflicto en Colombia
desde tiempos desde nuestro origen mismo
como como surgimiento como República
desde el fortalecimiento del Estado
nación hay que resolver eso eso se
resuelve desde las bases desde la
construcción del tejido social desde la
legitimidad y desde el reconocimiento al
mismo estado y eso sería un factor
determinante para cortarle camino y
posibilidades a la delincuencia
organizada y a más expresiones de
violencia pues Alejandra y a Ricardo les
agradezco mucho se nos acaba el tiempo
esto tiene claramente muchas más aristas
para analizar pero así Le damos un
panorama general por lo menos a los
televidentes que están fuera de las
fronteras colombianas para entender el
inicio de esta mesa de diálogo entre el
eln y el gobierno colombiano en la
ciudad de Caracas les agradezco mucho
por haber hecho el análisis para nuestra
audiencia en nombre de todo el equipo
técnico también Les agradecemos a
ustedes la sintonía la producción del
programa estuvo a cargo de Giovanni
agudelo y la producción de invitados
estuvo a cargo de Tania Herrera
consecuencia de ir dejando sus
comentarios y preguntas a través de las
redes sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]